welcome back to new rock stars I'm
Hector Navaro helping to fill in while
Eric Voss is out on paternity leave yay
Eric so you get a video written and
hosted by me Marvel Studios the Marvel
Cinematic Universe an official timeline
written by Anthony bresnen Amy Ratcliffe
and Rebecca Theodor vashan was recently
released and has given us MCU fans its
clearest and cleanest look at the sacred
timeline so far providing tons of
clarity fixing some errors in continuity
and gifting us with even more temporal
implications or tempations than ever
before so we're here to break it all
down for you but because the MCU
timeline spans from the literal dawn of
the universe to the year 2026 and Beyond
we're just going to focus on all the
projects coming from Marvel Studios that
are set post Avengers endgame meaning
phases four and five to help us better
understand exactly what's been going
down in the MCU as of late an official
timeline is an absolutely gorgeous book
and has a real Marvel no prize energy in
the way it uses the TVA and Miss minutes
as the device to bring us the reader
through the events of time including the
fact that mistakes and errors can happen
after all the sacred timeline has to
generate a lot of paperwork for the TVA
and we all know how convoluted paperwork
can
get TPS reports so let's begin we know
that Avengers endgame starts in 2018 and
jumps to 5 years later to wrap up its
events in Fall of 2023 where Loki also
branched off after he stole the Tess act
during the Time Heist to 2012 that Loki
got captured by the TVA and taken to the
organization's headquarters which exists
outside of time and space and leads to
the events of the Loki Series so we'll
pick up with that later the MCU in
Timeline order on Disney plus has Loki
placed after endgame and what if placed
after that which makes sense considering
the Multiverse creating events of season
1 of Loki and we also knew that Wan
division took place 3 weeks after the
ending of Avengers endgame and we get
our first tempation here when an
official timeline points out that during
a briefing Jimmy woo says the maximoffs
were born in 1989 but the file on screen
says their birth happened in 1988 Miss
minutes says it could be because records
were destroyed during sovia various
conflicts so there you go Marvel no
prize energy then moving into spring of
2024 the events of shangqi and the
legend of the 10 Rings takes place also
in Spring of 2024 the beginning of the
Falcon and the Winter Soldier occur
specifically the first 5 and a half
episodes of the miniseries up to the
point where the DOR malag arrive and
escort Baron helmet Zemo back to the
raft and buck asks the Dora for a favor
which end up being vibranium wings for
Sam Wilson who himself is training with
the Captain America shield before Bucky
delivers an apology for not knowing what
it would mean to hand The Shield to Sam
next as we learned from the opening of
black panther wakanda forever set in
Spring of 2025 King tchala dies a year
earlier in Spring of 2024 and his
funeral is held in wakanda after that in
summer of 2024 the events of Spider-Man
far from home begin and end here our
second tempation occurs when Mis minutes
acknowledges that Mysterio con man
Quenton Beck knew that the sacred
timeline used the designation Earth 616
but miss mines suggests it could be
because Beck or his team looked at some
of Eric selvig's theories from more than
a decade earlier where we saw in Thor
the Dark World that he had scribbled the
phrase 616 Universe on a chalkboard
before being released from treatment
which Miss Min chocks up to Selvig being
ahead of the curve okay weird if you
care about the Sony Spider-Man movies it
don't feature Spider-Man the film Venom
Let There Be Carnage would fit perfectly
in here in a viewing order as the
mid-credit scene brings venom Eddie
Brock into the sacred timeline so he can
lick a TV screen but right after that TV
licking we rejoined the Falcon and the
Winter Soldier miniseries for its last
episode also taking place in summer of
2024 with this story seeing Sam Wilson
accept the mantle of Captain America
with a fresh set of vibranium wings and
take down terrorists in New York City we
get some new tempations the first one is
that will Condon scientists and
technicians and possibly Sher herself
built These Wings for cap during or
right after their King tala's death
which is very Bittersweet and implies
that wakanda was ready to help usher in
a new hero after losing their own the
second implication is that either Sam
Wilson's fight with the flag Smashers
was happening while Peter Parker was
still in Europe a little overlap that
could explain why Spidey didn't arrive
to help cap in NYC or even if the fight
at the global repatriation council is
happening after Peter gets back back
from his vacation and his identity is
revealed to the world it would also help
explain why Spidey was maybe not in the
best place to help Captain America Peter
had to figure out how to hire a lawyer
after all and that brings us to the
start of Spider-Man no way home
beginning in Fall 2024 where Peter and
Aunt May hire a really good lawyer Matt
Murdoch and Peter begins his last year
of high school but before we can finish
up the events of that movie we have to
move on to another eternals also taking
place during fall of 2024 the remaining
gathered eternals are able to prevent
the emergence from destroying the planet
leaving a massive petrified Celestial
sticking out of the Indian Ocean our
next implication is that since eternals
takes place in Fall of 2024 that means
only three full MCU projects take place
before the celestial is referenced again
in shehulk attorney at law but that also
means 15 MCU projects have been released
since that haven't Revisited the topic
rumors are Captain America Brave New
World will tackle the celestial but
we'll see in February 2025 back in the
sacred timeline in October 2024 arim
arrives in the outer atmosphere of Earth
to declare that he will spare humanity
and return for judgment and after AOS
and pip arrive on the Domo in space and
danne Whitman gets visited by blade on
Earth we return to the continuing
Adventures of Peter
Parker one shot energy huh okay I'll try
it oh
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah w
what does one shot's Focus chew
do
eternity waa one shot really is all you
need begin your transformation with one
shot energy today by going to oneshot
energy.com new rockstars for 10% off
your order taking place in the very
packed fall of 2024 the rest of the
events of Spider-Man no way home occur
ending with Doctor Strange's spell
erasing the entire planet's memory of
Peter Parker's existence again if you
care about Sony Spider-Man movies that
don't feature Spider-Man their meme hit
morbius would go here as their mid
credit scene features Michael Keaton's
Adrien tombs being somehow sent to the
morbius universe to clumsily ask for a
team up with the Vampire superhero after
Spider-Man no way home but still taking
place in Fall of 2024 is Dr strange in
the Multiverse of Madness an official
timeline summarizes the film's finale by
saying that quote as the kindly 838
Wanda gathers the boys and assures the
heartbroken Scarlet Witch they will be
loved the Wanda maximoff of universe 616
surrenders she destroys oneor and
collapses it upon herself ending two
great threats to all the Multiverse
that's certainly not a definitive death
for Scarlet Witch just a quote ending of
a threat so our next tempation is that
it's entirely possible for one maximoff
of universe 616 to return next in
December of 2024 we see Peter Parker
visit MJ in a coffee shop where he
decides not to tell her who he is
sparing her potential pain and then in a
newly sewn and perfect Spider-Man suit
Peter swings by the giant Christmas tree
at Rockefeller Center where Hawkeye will
soon fight kingpin's minions so Hawkeye
is next just the first three and a half
episodes beginning with Kate Bishop's
prank on her college campus where she
accidentally destroys stain Tower named
after after obadi stain before his death
and ending with Kate's mom meeting Clint
Barton and then making a call to a
mysterious person who ends up being
Contessa Valentina algra defontaine who
then recruits yena Bova sister of the
deceased Natasha Romanov for a mission
yena is at her sister's Memorial in the
post-credit scene of Black Widow where
she says you're not supposed to be
bothering me on my Holiday Time
Valentina which is our next templi
cation because that lines up with the
holiday setting of Hawkeye then the last
three episodes of Hawkeye take place
ending on December 25th Christmas Day
when Kate Bishop joins Clint Barton for
a family holiday moving into the year
2025 the first three episodes of
She-Hulk attorney at law occur in the
spring from Jennifer Walter's opening
court case that gets crashed by social
media influencer Titania to her fighting
off the Asgardian empowered Wrecking
Crew outside of her apartment then also
in Spring of 2025 are the events of
moonnight every episode our next
tempation is that an official timeline
points out that Mark Spectre had a
passport issued in December 2018 meaning
he was active after the blip and during
the 5 years everyone was gone the
beginning of Thor love and thunder is
next in Spring of 2025 where Jane Foster
is battling cancer before journeying to
new Asgard to see molier reform in front
of her to make her The Mighty Thor and
then still in Spring of 2025 the events
of black panther wakanda forever play
out Queen ramonda faces members of the
United Nations all the way until the New
Black Panther Shu Mourns her brother on
a beach in Haiti beginning in Spring and
moving into the summer and fall of 2025
the rest of She-Hulk attorney at law
takes place episodes 4-9 with our next
tempation happening which is Jennifer
Walters herself crosses out and rewrites
the entries for her last episode in the
official timeline book seizing control
of her own narrative look at that
excellent touch also in the fall of 2025
we see the events of M Marvel occur
which include Kamala Khan traveling back
to Summer 1947 on the sacred timeline to
help her own Grand grandmother find her
family during the British mandated
partition of India on an unverified date
a father named Gore's daughter dies and
then he finds an oasis where he uses the
necros sword to begin killing the gods
who didn't answer his prayers in Fall of
2025 the God of Thunder reunites with
the new Mighty Thor and they team up to
take down Gore the god butcher during
the events of Thor love and thunder we
get a few new tempations here the first
being that because Thor and Jane broke
up quote 8 years 7 months and 6 days
before that means they broke up sometime
in early 2017 and that implies that Thor
really dove into his work afterwards and
left for the Stars investigating
infinity stone things the second is that
it's still unclear how teenager Groot
can look exactly the same in love and
thunder as he did 2 years prior when he
came back from the blip in Fall of 2023
but just a few months from now looked
like a very swole Groot during their
holiday festivities well look I don't
know how Flora Colossus grows that's
none of my business maybe Groot was
inspired by Thor's trans transformation
and really hit the gym afterwards the
werewolf By Night Special occurs or
seems to occur next during the fall of
2025 although Miss minutes hits us with
our next tempation with a TVA alert that
states magical influences can make stuff
like this hard to pin down sound like
Holly Hunter that's Miss is incredible
for you young people and rounding out
phase four of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe is the Guardians of the Galaxy
holiday special taking place in December
of 2025 mantis tells Star-Lord she's his
sister and Kevin B is kidnapped and
returned home we don't know exactly
where the projects in Phase 5 take place
but we can pretty much place them on the
timeline by moving into the year 2026
having the first two episodes of Loki
season 2 take place before Ant-Man in
the was Quant Mania which takes place in
July of 2026 thanks to a sign for Scott
Lang's book signing being on July 24th
and the movie being placed after the
Guardians holiday special on the MCU in
Timeline order on Disney plus even
though Loki is outside of time the
post-credit scene of quantum Mania
featured to tease for Loki season 2
episode 3 so after Loki season 2 is
wrapped up we move on to Guardians of
the Galaxy volume 3 then secret Invasion
then the mid credit scene of the last
episode of M Marvel which featured a
sneak peek at the next and most recent
project on the timeline the Marvels and
that's not even all of the newly
resurfaced tempations we get from an
official timeline if you want to see us
talk about even more check out the
breakroom Channel where we cover the
rest in some fun conversations and
answer your burning questions about the
MCU and there you have it folks phases
four and five so far of the MCU in the
correct so far timeline order follow our
three new rockstars channels follow me
at Hector is funny and at Heroes
reforged on YouTube and have a great and
safe holiday we'll see you
[Music]
bye